this is a sickness my father used to say
he used to say
my question for you is how much money do
you think a guy should make per year
[Music]
um it depends where they live I mean if
I'm like dating them it'd be nice if
they were at least making a hundred
thousand
um
like a million two million
okay we're at ASU you know so you're not
gonna find him here like fully like
adult someone that you would consider
wanting to be with the rest of your life
300 okay three figures
okay so why is that
just because like that's a stable income
I'd say 100 like 500 Grand is that a lot
no that's 500 is like normal
on a good day yeah I mean it depends
okay uh a lot we're expensive yeah Mills
Millions Mills [ __ ] okay I don't really
care okay two things are crossing my
mind I know a lot of you guys like all
these women are unreasonable I think I'm
also understanding that I think a lot of
you don't even know they don't
understand money
they they don't understand being
University not paying for it they don't
know
oh no maybe it's because at 18 I already
had a job
and I was working consistently and
paying my own rent maybe that's why they
have no [ __ ] clue what these incomes
look like but what is also interesting
is that they said 500k is that normal uh
yeah if you have a Fortune 500 company
what the [ __ ] are you talking about 500
600k
703 million I like Millies
can I get two Millie what
[ __ ] I'm so old that when I
started working the minimum wage was
680.
yeah that's why you remember when you
used to get like a 20 20 increase on the
minimum wage and you got excited
you can buy three more Burgers what is
this [ __ ] so what he said that we were
like
yeah
I was working at Six Flags
since 80 it was not even Six Flags at
680 at a [ __ ] hour yeah
and you gonna talk about
that was that was a different time hey
bro I bust my ass yeah back then you
made ten dollars an hour you were
balling yeah
yeah these girls watch you making 15 now
this shit's crazy with inflation I'm so
old brother
Relic bro you could they about to stick
your ass in the museum and [ __ ]
come and press a button and you would
just be there like back in my day we
used to make 680 an hour
Good Times how's the weather gone bro
stick me with the fossils and [ __ ]
I mean I like when guys like pay for
dates and stuff
30k a year is that something you're okay
with yeah I think that would be great
like your husband oh [ __ ] husband yeah I
think I would be fine if it was my
husband I'd be in love with him so yeah
see this naivete on both sides she's
like she's fine with him if he just
makes 30k and your husband which is like
no like you need to be hitting around
closer to 40 50. generally in a lot of
Miss American cities so it's not even
town they even her even though her
answer was a lot more wholesome and nice
even she doesn't have a real good
concept of money they don't know they
don't know we could we could trash all
that but they don't do they even know
what the [ __ ] they're saying it don't
sound like it but the worry becomes we
see older women saying a lot of this
goofier [ __ ] too and you wonder like how
many of these women ever graduate to
understand money or is it that they
don't understand money they're just
actually [ __ ] with their
expectations
these [ __ ] actually work or
they go to school school I'm not under
the impression that these [ __ ]
were well that's a good question we'll
find out if we're clowning everything
about me being old and [ __ ] like that
but I think that's very important once
you get that first check yes and they
told you a prize and then when all the
insurance and this and that gets off
your paycheck and you're like wait a
[ __ ] mint I'm not wait a minute I'm
not supposed so everybody like that so
when you're doing a 100K it's actually
65. yeah so so if you don't know that I
don't feel like they do then I'm not
gonna work I'm gonna I'm not gonna take
the word for it but I've heard some 30
year old woman
say this stuff say this [ __ ] and I'm
like you've been working yeah you've
been having a paycheck you know how hard
it is yeah
minimum six figures
the mess of Lifestyle yeah no I mean I
totally understand we got to get good
skin care routine you know the whole
whole nine yards 100 000
or 20K
one girl's 120 comes like [ __ ] I'm
worth more than you 120k
[ __ ]
I got one girl 100 that was 120 what a
random number to just come out with 80k
and like maybe like 120. okay yeah I
would say like 80 to 150. okay no no
stop stop I don't care if they don't all
understand it the fact that they all say
the same numbers is indication of
something
even average busted looking broads are
saying they need Partners making that
much because they don't know but it does
sound good
that okay I agree that they may not know
I'm asking you why do they all say
around the same number because it sounds
good uh 100 is always a good number
100 a hundred say it again 100 whoa 100
sounds good yo sounds good 100 a month
100K that sounds even better okay I can
see like a hundred that's that that's
that's a threshold yeah that's why you
you 100K you want another category you
know I mean you're above that's why all
these prizes that's when you go shopping
it's like 9.99 because you didn't bust a
threshold you don't think you're paying
ten dollars you're paying nine bucks 99
cents of course same same yeah but
because 10 sounds bigger 100 sounds
bigger 50 sounds better than 49.99 it's
really the same thing interesting right
I really feel like
but I'm curious where did they get 100k
from the rather than 50k why are they
all saying 100K that's what I want to
know that means that they're getting
those their cues from somewhere on what
they should look for in a man because
they're all coming with the same answer
yeah that wouldn't happen that's what
I'm interested in now yeah we they're
all saying they're the same range why is
that and I think that's a media thing
yes I suspect but but I agree with you
that they don't understand money I
suspect the reason why they hit that
Benchmark minimum is because of that
what does 100K say to you
a hundred he says he's in a suit he
looked good he got a briefcase that's a
100K okay to me just says he good these
women
it's not just about he good no me what
does it look like okay I don't think
they're thinking briefcases no not
briefcases but 100K like your success
there's a certain type of man with a
100K I think they're thinking you're
successful
hear that if he was doing crypto
and looking on whatever and he's making
200 they're gonna be like
you're 200 but you don't look you don't
look 200. you think so I don't think so
I think let us know I don't think so I
let I don't think they would care if
it's crypto or not over 100k once you
get to a certain age like I don't know
I'm also kind of like gold digger so no
um I'm planning on just like supporting
myself
um with my income so I don't really plan
on being supported by the person that
I'm dating what is the lowest you would
go though
um foreign
this is a sickness it is like a virgin
who are telling you how to stroke it
is
yes yes yes you are remaining a virgin
you are going to say that we are going
to die that my father used to say he
used to say he used to say a the Early
Bird eats everything my father used to
say he used to say
we mean they are like a box of
chocolates
you eat them and you get cavities
what's the lowest though that you would
go for
um I don't think money is stopping uh
maybe like a
uh it has to be you just said one or two
mil
two calls under [ __ ] thank you very
much would you be down for 80. yeah 80
60. that'd be fine okay okay that's fair
enough uh
a half a million yeah okay okay you know
what I'm gonna stop it here I don't want
to play the rest of the video because I
think what we're learning is that a lot
of Young Americans are just absolutely
financially illiterate which is not like
the worst thing in the world because I
you know
they don't teach you finances but it
also shows that most of them have never
had a job they've never worked in a
professional setting ever which is
unfortunate I think it's a big
disservice I think Young Folks should
100 get side jobs if possible or just
have some concept of money uh that even
their parents can teach them because let
me tell you the [ __ ] I was hearing here
I'd never heard my entire life growing
up my entire life I've never heard
people talk like this ever
no this is a new thing that we're not
blackmatics they were not talking
figures they would just say I want a
rich man but it was really something
playful in that they were not really
about that in my days you know what it
was or what was it can you just have a
nice car in a nice place
no that's what it was if you told her
you had a child you had a nice car
you're a nice place you was getting them
drawers you're not wrong she was down
now it's a different thing there's like
extreme figures and everyone's saying
it's a different Balkan in those years
those age teams age because they they're
late teens if you had a place if you
were not living at your mama's Hey
listen there's a reason why your boy
moved out at 17 because uh you know Mom
was too busy putting on the hijab during
her uh Hadith you know what I'm saying
she was praying wasn't going to be
clapping no cheeks not in her home
became roommates at a different place
yeah get into that let me tell you I was
up in some meat but it wasn't Hala you
feel me dead that was some Haram
sandwich yes I didn't go to the mosque
on Friday I went to the club on Friday
night yeah yeah
it's all this to say things have changed
and I'm seeing now that this change
people can say uh inflation it's not
inflation okay 100K combined household
income is more than enough for ghost
families in a lot of major cities
there's a few exceptions but most places
you're gonna be all right and even those
exceptions if you move far enough to
suburbs you're gonna be okay this
[ __ ] went to the club not the
mosque it was not my it's not it was not
Bismillah it was [ __ ] holla
that's you
comment no comments no comment no
comments you already commented yeah you
did I'm not gonna maybe you guys
disagree let us know what you think they
just don't know yeah